[Applaudissements]
mais oui hier soir un nouvel épisode de
l'amour est dans le pré sur m6 les
audiences s'il vous plaît monsieur donc
l'amour est dans le pré a été battu par
tf1 et la fiction de l'événement oui la
fiction événement avec kad merad la part
de soupçons mais ils ont quand même fait
3,6 millions et plus de 350000 des
spectacles alors la part du soupçon donc
avec kad merad qui était excellent
dedans 4,9 millions en tout parce que
voilà ça fait 5 millions 1 sur le
premier épisode etc et 4 et quelques sur
l'autre l'amour est dans le pré 2e à 3
millions 6 qui se maintient pas mal
quand même
il y avait eu b voilà c'est un mec voilà
qui je vais y avait là prennent la
manucure et il avait w9 parker j'ai
passé mon le lieu merci
il y avait par coeur c'est un film sur
le basket hier donc on avait un nouvel
épisode de l'amour est dans le pré plus
350 mille téléspectateurs en une semaine
quand même et on va vous faire la soirée
minute par minute à 21h10 et le
générique de début
l'émission commence bien entendu on
adore le générique et bah ils auraient
dû le m me n'ont pas mis et à 21h21 on a
eu leur trouvaille de cécile et laurent
à la gare les deux sont très gentils
mais apparemment n'avait pas grand chose
à dire c'est ce qui se passe souvent
dans l'amour est dans le pré est normal
s'il ya un truc à retenir c'est que
c'est bien on vers dieu
ils se sont dits oui toi très bien bien
sa voix tu vas pas très bien j'aime
beaucoup et bien très très bien d'accord
oui bon ça va vite ça va oui oui oui
martin blanchet bien voir une heure
voire chaillé chaillé ouais ça j'y suis
arrivé
[Applaudissements]
ok mais l'amour est dans le pré donc il
y aurait oui parce que c'est les gens
qu'on voit jamais autrement la
télévision il vient d'un monde qui est
en train de mourir qui est très
difficile et moi je trouve ça très
émouvant de leur donner la parole de
voilà de voir à quoi il ressemble sinon
vous ne les croisés jamais alors laurent
qu'on vient voir c'est un des chouchous
voilà il certains le trouvent peut-être
même un peu trop gentil mais sur twitter
et push beaucoup beaucoup de monde
voilà il est touchant et attachant
l'orangé encore les larmes aux yeux en
regardant l'amour est dans le pré une
belle personne avec une belle âme
oui ça c'est vrai laurent méric le
bonheur ils me trouvent trop cet homme
vous jean-michel mais on n'est pas
d'accord avec eric non non je veux
d'accord avec eric parce que même si je
défends les agriculteurs mon grand-père
était paysan dans le jura voilà ce qu'il
ya d'autres moyens de montrer le travail
des agriculteurs de leur rendre au nom
de ses émissions sur cette saison là oui
cette saison qui est très mollassonne
moi je regrette si c'est très grave
quand il y avait des défis kinect des
talons de basseau de sa mère et qui
venaient en minijupe et il n'est
peut-être pas pour tout le monde chez
moi faisait le spectacle c'est au nom se
marrait la smartpad s'étaient eux c'est
chiant alors abattue sur 28
on a vue fatima afu avec didier c'est la
petite polémique de ce début de saison
certains ont peur que fatima la
prétendante de didier le manipule alors
c'est ce qui ressort sur les réseaux
sociaux
après c'est sûr qu'elle est vraiment à
fond sur dix dit regardez vous a fait
une petite compris ça et je vénère
habiter chez toi et voilà vous attend
vous redis
puis sorlin viennent de but et ça cette
nana là bien de la viande
bon appétit - chéri mais voilà moi
j'essaye de le séduire fort - charme
faire ce qu'on me demande de faire
tu veux francs dans ses bras je t'aime
comme il a les yeux revolver montdidier
yalova m shon des massages en wallonie
[Musique]
walla walla des mercis
10 le merdy qui va à fond avec d'idées
alors surtout quand il y en a beaucoup
qui ont peur que 10 face manipuler adp à
l'état font là fatima je suis deg de
fatima sérieux elles le palais manipule
avec ses chéris et faire comme s'ils
étaient mariés comme ça et ça il sera il
sera mal s'il choisit l'autre voilà il y
en a plein voilà qui sont pas si mart et
les modèles du bon parce que ça sonne
faux mois pour moi de didier c'est la
star du programme c'est sympa où il ne
trouve absolument formidable il faut
arrêter de penser que ce garçon est pas
capable de réfléchir par lui même enfin
c'est quoi cette condescendance en
disant oh le pauvre il est manipulé et
s' est un grand garçon et il est
suffisamment capables de savoir s'il a
envie ou pas d'être avec cette femme
et si cette femme le manipule et
peut-être même qu'elle le manitou dès
qu'il en a envie
et bien c'est tout 21h31 on a vu une des
séquences les plus touchants de
l'émission cerner encore de notre didier
didier il veut pas faire de peine aux
candidats très heureux mais je tiens à
saluer m
john ani le changement c'est maintenant
secondaire guiglo man que 5 hommes
d'hugo boss très bas pour les ce et de
stress doit arriver à dire qu'ils
aiguisent occasion ferrain
j'oubliais tu t'es pas eu lieu vers non
à celles alliées comme ça te fait un
exposé à paris les le domaine nos
modules et moi
topal et mouret s'il adore voilà il est
triste car vous n'aimez pas maintenant
typiquement ce genre de séquences non
j'aime pas non avec le piano derrière la
musique généreuse m'étonne quand l'amour
vélo marais tu arrêtes toi le premier tu
lisais dans une émission notre jour que
quand il y avait trop de musique quand
on force l émotion franchement voilà
alors regardez occasion de voir toujours
la même émission de saison en saison
on répète toujours les mêmes choses
assez 1 ça ne m'intéresse pas alors et
quand je ne reproche pas mais c'est un
concept auquel je n'adhère pas voilà je
le respecte mais je n'adhère pas alors
elle ne tombe super condescendant mais
c'est pas être présent dans les halles
droitière du mal et la démission d'henri
la droite dire la france agathe vous
aimez vous par exemple
ah oui moi j'aime exactement pour les
mêmes raisons que tu détestes jean-mi
parce que je suis assez friands de télé
réalité et pour le coup j'aimerais qu'on
clôture ce débat l'amour est dans le pré
c'est typiquement de la télé-réalité les
candidats sont de plus en plus
caricaturaux je pense pas qu'on ait eu
une saison avec des candidats aussi
caricaturaux c'est extrêmement scénarisé
au final ça fait un bon divertissement
alors à 21h44 c'est le début des
problèmes pour julien et yannick si vous
ne connaissez pas leur julien ganic ils
ce sont les prénoms en prétendant de
sandrine elle leur annonce qu'ils ne
vont pas dormir chez elle et c'est que
le début regardez vous allez comprendre
pourquoi
j'avais trois charmants donc on est une
tente
pourquoi pas la tente amandine hockey
[Musique]
mais les sardines puisque j'ai roulé
mais moi je suis face à un défi à des
chefs de chantier y mettre une sourdine
aux opérateurs s'est passé pas
chronométré ton truc ça va les gars sont
en fait c'est bon on l'a fait le plus
dur la [ __ ] les voisins ils sont
bruyants et polenta abbas campus
lendemain ils vont pas être tranquille
leur demande de faire un autre truc
les gars ils sont au bout du rouleau à
mon avis on veut se débarrasser les deux
prétendants c'est sûr et certain regard
pour nettoyer tous les cas mais ça va on
sait par quoi rappeler les pieds
mouillés
[Musique]
car tu files et fixer les coûts de j'ai
choisi parce qu'aucune fille tu prends
la rallonge partiel barque jeter un côté
hip hop quand tu travailles sur la
casquette à l'envers
sympa c'est avec quelques pas de danse
en m'appelant bon je prends mon bâton ça
m'attire pas trop ça tient pas francis
[Musique]
hallé pompidou un enfer oui la belle
elles sont souvent quand on regarde
toutes les saisons de l'amour est dans
le pré les femmes sont tous plus dur
ouais c'est vrai ça c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est un conte
castratrice aller au violet comme la
livre comme un bijou il répond non moi
j'aime beaucoup ces démissions de j'aime
bien comme a expliqué me l'a expliqué
valérie moi j'adore j'ai mené j'ai bien
aimé didier qui pleurent même s'il est
en train de se faire carottes par une
meuf qui vivent sont aventurés ciel le
carottes et bah c'est pas grave à la
carotte
il pleure un bon coup et c'est un grand
garçon il s'en remettra petit bémol là
j'ai pas compris parce qu'ils les dames
quatre chiens là dedans c'est tout trois
chiens et une chèvre ou à la partie
c'est l'heure de la consécration didier
fatima passer un bon moment au resto le
et apparemment et qui fait tellement le
moment qu'ils ont décidé d'aller plus
loin
ça c'est pêchu ya non il sans rigoler je
t'ai comment ou franchement ça commence
à s'embrasser ou jetés sur crime d'amour
au dessus de 500 da je trouve y avait un
crime d'embrassades regarder
et même en parler bambin
je peux répéter de ma vie j'étais passé
nous l'a tuée je t'aime belles années
comme un amour go
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça c'est une
ça c'est que ce soit ça c'est ce mac et
ça c'est ce mac est sévère a franchement
et aux rémois et juste après je vous
montrais l'extrait le plus drôle de
l'amour est dans le pré hier c'est que
didier après s'est senti obligé de te
pousser la chansonnette
c'était très très fort kelly vous adorez
les méchants que j'adore cette émission
regardée que les noces est vrai que
l'extrait avec les pas celui ci met les
jeunes d'avant je suis d'accord avec
agathe ça fait un peu télé réalité et
c'est vrai que je suis un peu déçu cette
année dense que d'habitude justement moi
je trouve que c'est des personnes qui
sont vraiment entière sensible et
honnête
hélas ça ne dérange un peu plus sages
attendue plex avec quelqu'un je l'aurais
jamais vraiment percé à d'accord mais
très bien
ouais c'est ça qui me dérange cette
année c'est le côté un petit peu télé
réalité que non pas du tout mais ça va
pas du tout télé réalité contrairement à
ce qu'on a vu la bataille des coupes de
céder je vous le dis tout acte inédit
jean didier se met à chanter et là c'est
la barca je t'aime avec mon coeur je
t'aime avec ma peau je t'aime avec un
peu c'est vrai je t'aime tôt le diable
et le bon dieu peuvent dormir
tranquilles d'anvers et d'être 2 le ciel
est si fragile
[Applaudissements]
du
il
j'aime bien pas l'amour et dont faisait
partie le tombale j'aime trop 3 %
viennent pas à 67% vers se disent ira
les chercher celle inverse se dissipe